okay your life
thanks okay morning everybody we will um
make a start so welcome to today's
meeting with the public engagement board
um an interesting morning i think as
we've got the um
the government's chief scientists
addressing the nation at 11 o'clock so
it'll be interesting to see what comes
out of there but in terms
of apologies for um today we've received
apologies from mandy bailey
um michelle hill and debbie walsh
um but we seem to have a fairly good
turnout otherwise so that's that's good
um can i just check if there are any
declarations of interest in
any items on the agenda at all
no okay great um and that brings us to
the minutes of the meeting of the
third of september are people happy with
those are there any questions or
comments on those at all
no okay so we will approve those
thanks everybody item four is
um membership and forgive me i'm not
sure if there have been any
substantive changes since um the last
meeting that we need to note
um alex have there been any changes to
to the um membership since we last met
uh not since last meeting now no okay
that's great thank you so the membership
is
um as was so item five
is the update on the current um
situation in trafford 5a the health
protection board report in 5b
um the weekly briefing are we coming to
yourself for this eleanor
yes and i'm um i've been on holiday for
two weeks so i'm i'm still playing catch
up
um but obviously as um
as has been happening nationally um
we've been seeing
an increase in the number of um cases in
trafford
um i'm not sure if there's anyone else
on the call now
um so it it is a question of
um obviously we're in um
in not in the situation we want to be in
at all
um i think that what we need to be
focusing on now and there's been a lot
of
obviously there's been a lot of press
interest um and
commentary on the testing and the
contact racing elements
um and issues with that and that
obviously has been affecting us quite
badly in traffic
as everywhere else um i suppose what
i've really been wanting us to be
focusing on
for the board is two things one is
um trying to really reinforce that
message about
um get a test when you're symptomatic
that's the time when a test is most
likely to show positive
and that is really the most important
time to get
a test and the second thing is if you
are a contact
of somebody and you've been told to
self-isolate
there's really no point in getting a
test unless you are you yourself are
symptomatic
we really do need to make sure that
people aren't going for tests
and then perhaps when you know if
they're asked to self-isolate because
they're a contact
um and then they think i'll go for a
test well even if that whatever that
test comes if that test comes back
negative you still have to self-isolate
so it's really trying to make sure
that we can work with people um and and
use this board and other means to make
sure those messages really get out to
people because i'm not sure that
that message has really been fully
understood
and the second thing that i think
perhaps
that we need to be really focusing on is
if somebody in your household
is um symptomatic or has tested positive
the household hygiene needs to be
similar to if somebody had diarrhoea and
vomiting
so you really need to make sure that the
you know your the bathroom hygiene the
kitchen hygiene everything else is
absolutely tip-top
um to make sure that we don't get any
household spread so those i think are
the
main messages that i want to make sure
people are
we're able to try and make sure that we
aren't people are getting those messages
and i suppose i'll be interested in the
views of of the
committee of the board on how we get
those messages out and whether people in
the group have any concerns about any of
those methods messaging
thanks elena any any questions or
comments on that i mean
clearly the comms on this needs needs to
be
as sharp as possible because people are
getting incredibly confused with all of
the
very various restrictions and different
pieces of information that are coming
out
all the time but perhaps if if not at
this point
um then have a think about that i know
comms is
is further down on the agenda as well so
do keep that
um in mind if not was there anything you
wanted to say on the ten point plan i
wonder
so we've got the um escalation the
escalation
plan haven't we and the um and the
10-point plan we've got some
escalation points and action points so
just running through those
we've got the um the work that we're
doing on
trying to make sure we get support the
um
appropriate ways of supporting the
differential impacts of covert 19 on
individuals and communities
and trying to just think about how we do
that that's just one of the groups
i'm very concerned about is our care
home residence and making sure that we
we're really trying to minimize that
social
that isolation from families and friends
um
with our care home residents and
thinking about how we
how we can support people with that one
i i don't know if people have any
comments on that
but it is that it is really about the
messaging again a lot of this is
obviously about the comms and engagement
on this
certainly i know i contacted diane last
week about this and
gm are looking for um you know a
potential solution around the care home
visits issue because this is going to be
an incredibly long hard winter for
people now and with the exception of
what a couple of couple of weeks in june
july time people are now
facing you know six months plus of not
being able to
see their family if they're in care
homes so so i know
um people are trying to pull a solution
together but i'll bring diane in
who's indicated hi diane hello andrew
thank you
for that i just wanted to give people
assurance there was a lot of
press activity around our care homes
last week
that many of you will have seen and we
have written out
all our care homes all the residents and
families and the staff who work in those
um facilities to assure them um
obviously as a as an authority we need
to support everybody
including people who are coveted
positive
and but we will do that in a very safe
way in uh
separate facilities and and part of our
contracting is to try and source those
facility arrangements
um and on the visiting side we have had
a joint paper go across all of the
uh 10 gm authorities up to the leaders
group
with the andy burnham to assure that we
have got support
to explore all the possible ways that we
can get families in to see people
safely and not spread any further
infection
we have got an infection control fund
which has just been announced as being
extended nationally
as part of the winter plan and we have
written again to care homes who haven't
taken up the offer
of a of us paying for a visiting
facility like a
pod in the garden or separate room
isolating cleaning
etc because we want to try and get some
agreed gm
way forward and i'll feed back on that
soon as we've confirmed a process andrew
right thank you
oh hello there um yeah it was not
related to care homes but i was just
wondering about
um schools um and specifically i'm
asking around
the effect it has on gps if they're a
parent
so whereby schools might have um a
policy of not
sending in until children have had a
test if their parents are gps it's
obviously having the knock-on effect
for them not being able to go into
practice
and surgery and i just wondered if there
was going to be or
currently is any sort of service to gp
so they can get tested
as a priority
the children sorry
just with you being off elena i was just
going to say we have been working across
gm
last week um eve to try and get some
agreed
access to pillow on testing for privacy
staff and
primary care obviously fits into that as
does our
teachers and our social care staff and
we're hoping that that will go back to
adas on tuesday and if the
directors of public health are in
agreement um we have got
support from gm across accessing some of
that pillow on testing at the lab
capacity
and i think there's an extra clinic
being set up and we're just working out
who would be in that priority group um
so absolutely um you know the the impact
of the children um i mean it is right
though that well
if the children are symptomatic they do
need to stay off well
while they're waiting for those tests
but we we do have to make sure that they
can get the test quickly
okay um
so running down the rest of the ten
point plan we've got
a section on um the support on testing
to workplaces and so on
obviously we've got the traffic park um
and parkinson's sites up and running now
which we didn't have but i know there
have been a lot of um
you know the the issues and the national
issues are playing out locally
as well but those sites i think are
being quite busy um in terms of the
clinical
the community hubs um joe i don't know
if there's anything you want to add on
the community hubs
um and support that they're giving to
people who are clinically vulnerable
i think there's been there's more
guidance expected for this group isn't
there
yeah there is so so our community hub
offer is is still
um up and running um there's not an
awful lot of demand coming through via
our kind of central response line at the
moment
um but in terms of making sure that that
continues we're also going to step up um
especially for clinically extremely
vulnerable people we're just going to
make sure that we've got a
plan in place for stepping shielding
support back up
and so we're working closely with the
ccg in order to sort of understand
those numbers um and the support that
will be
needed there so there'll be a different
way that people would register
um but they would also be and
prioritized for
online shopping and stuff like that but
we will have our community
hubs in existence to help with with the
support there as well
brilliant and i think we're still i
think there may be more announcements
later today on the
national um systems for that so we'll
we'll see what
happens there um in terms of infection
control
and um ppe we are
recruiting now to our swabbing team and
also recruiting to
replace um our infection control lead
nurse who's requiring
um uh but i think currently there aren't
any
particular issues with ppe and
um laura will be able to say more about
this but i think we now have
um the right masks and so on for the
aerosol generating procedures so that is
very good news
um more on testing
um swabbing which we've just covered um
and the laura is there anything
we need to say about um the
emergency ppe supplies i think all of
that is running quite smoothly isn't it
yeah i mean we've got the the smithfield
hub
um is in place to provide kind of
emergency access to ppe the national
team are mobilizing
um the ebay portal i think it's called
the clipper system
which is going to hopefully become the
sort of vau supply for
services in terms of ppe there's been
sort of restrictions in terms of limits
to be ordered via that um and
restrictions on the services that that
are included on that
but the goat is kind of ever increasing
and ever mobilizing so hopefully
the need for ppe via the mutual aid hub
should shrink as the national plans kind
of
expand um i think you know just to say
that that obviously the mutual aid hub
is there and i know we've been working
with
with george around the voluntary
etc um but you know there's anything
anything else that we can be doing to
making sure you know good infection
control practices are in place and that
we're reaching
you know any any groups whether they're
voluntary groups
or other um just just to sort of let us
know really
i am did you want to come in sorry um it
was just to say that the
the adult social care winter plan was
also published by the government
on friday which indicates free ppe
um regulated services through the portal
that laura's just described and
unregulated services through the council
so we're just reviewing that
um new initiative
okay thanks um any any more on the ten
point plan elena
or i think that's i think that's it yeah
for now the contain the contained
measures obviously have been um
subject of um you know a lot of nation
i imagine that's you know we've got with
we're still in our local restrictions
obviously in trafford
um and i imagine the chief medical
officer will be making more comments
um and proposals at 11 o'clock today so
i i haven't got any um advanced notice
of what might be
in there no need to revive so
um okay and um i guess
i guess your comments start with the
general situation but uh the weekly
briefing
anything in particular or
i need to catch up with it because i'm
still
um catching catching up so at the moment
i think
it's um i think with the number of cases
we're seeing and the trouble is because
the national delay with the testing
results we are getting the results
through quite late
yeah um so i think we just need to keep
um
keep working on this is going to be
something that is
um you know it is across the whole of
our population in traffic still we all
need to be really aware of it
and i think it's about um recognizing
that that we are going to this is going
to be
throughout the winter um we need to be
making sure that we're as well prepared
as we can be that we are taking the
personal responsibility we need to take
to try and keep ourselves keep that
social distancing
but at the same time you know exercise
is incredibly important trying to make
sure that people do get out and about
um although the rates are rising fast
they're not where they were in march
we just need to make sure they don't get
back to where they were
in march and april and that does mean
that you know that social distancing
um that and the hygiene and really
trying to make sure that if you are told
to self-isolate
that that people are able to do that and
and i suppose for this
from this group in particular i would be
really interested in
in feedback you have from the people you
know
about what the difficulties are and
what's what's happening with that and
how do we get
how do we get the messages through to
people in a way that is
helpful to them and and make it into
something that people can live with
because this has got to be something
that we're we're really doing through
engaging our population not trying to do
two people
otherwise people are just not going to
tell us the truth about who they've been
seeing and what's happening
so um it's it's really important that
that we can have an honest dialogue and
we can make sure that we do the things
that support people
to keep themselves and other people safe
thanks honor any any questions or
comments on that
um i mean clearly we're going into a
really important phase
over the next two or three weeks at
least so
um food food for thought if nobody
um wants to come in eve
hi uh yeah i just i guess just um
for something for consideration um
obviously there's a lot of um
pressure being placed on providers
whether it's gps or secondary care to
get services up and running again
and we know it's you know changing on a
daily basis and
we're yet to hear what's going to come
today but i think there's a real
um need to have some sort of uh public
and engagement piece around uh
getting that balance right because we
obviously don't want people not
attending if they're
if they're unwell for non-covered
reasons striking that balance with
keeping
themselves and also the workforce safe
and i think it's going to become very
confusing i mean
there's a lot of national bad press for
gps recently who have
been accused of not um seeing patients
face to face
when actually they were very much
informed at the beginning to do
everything virtually so i think it is a
confusing place for
the workforce in trafford as well as the
patients
and i and i'd like to work with those
involved in the comm
side to trafford residents to get that
pitched right
if if i may at some point please
yeah no i think that makes makes sense
and perhaps um
can pick up a conversation offline is
martin on the call
martin dylan yes andrew i am yeah
are you okay to take that away offline
martin if that's
all right sure seems good to
um get to get some intel on that
yeah and on the gp engagement because
what we have had is really good
messaging from our gps as well and
they've been incredibly helpful
in sending out message um uh messages to
the subsection of the population and
different messages to different groups
and we really appreciate that but also i
think the credibility of the message
that comes from the gps
so again linking the gps into some of
those messages about
hygiene in the home if there's if
there's somebody positive in the home
and also self-isolation will be really
powerful
yeah thanks um i've got michael then
andrew like
hi i'm just wondering you know in the
figures that we're
we're receiving um obviously we get uh
information about the
you know infection rates and the the
death rates but we're not seeing
i don't think i'm seeing anything on the
hospitalization rate
and i'm just wondering if it's possible
to uh you know
just to to see those or get those
included in the figures
um and particularly when you know one
comes to sort of share these share this
information
more widely that seems to be where a lot
of the skepticism is at the moment
it's about kind of you know well the
rate might be rising but is anybody you
know
is the hospitalization rate um rising
um it would be useful to be able to see
those figures you know easily
um yeah that would be great
thank you very much um and andrew
yeah it was just to reiterate on the
communication side
um some of you be aware that we're
conducting a survey at the minute
on people's experiences of accessing
health and social care services during
covid
and the interim findings we've got from
that are that gp surgeries television
social media
and friends and family are the most
accessed places for people to find
information
so it's really vital that those messages
that go out are consistent across all of
those channels
and in terms of um it'll come as no
surprise i should imagine but
clear communication was the one area
that people have identified so far as
being
the most obvious that could be improved
so it's really just making sure that
those messages are consistent
yeah that was it really yeah
okay great well that i think probably
brings us neatly on to our cons of
engagement strategy
um does it does it not yes developing
our constant engagement strategy and
action plan who is
leading us through this um
tracy i think you want to talk about the
work that's
going on already eleanor
oh sorry hi eleanor it's tom all right
sorry tom
tom yeah it's okay no worries i'll um
i'll i'll kick us off and tracy can uh
can definitely jump in with some uh some
information as well and an update if
that's okay
thank you um okay good morning everyone
um i think we've brought a discussion
here um to this board on
on a couple of occasions all about it
being relatively brief around
the desire to co-produce a
communications and engagement strategy
which was dealing with the here and now
in terms of covid but also the longer
term
which was linked to the production of
our trafford together locality plan
which is the health and social care plan
for the next five years which we did
at the back end of last year and
obviously that has been refreshed and
things have changed in light of covid
and we want that renewed commitment to
consistent and aligned communications
and engagement as a trafford system
everyone working together
and so the existing steering group has
been pulling that strategy together
behind the scenes for the last number of
weeks and months actually
um and a number of colleagues on the
call today
have been pivotal in getting it to the
place where it's at now and so
the idea is that we do have one strategy
for communications and engagement
traffic an absolute core part of that
will be around dealing with covid and
hence why we want this conversation here
for today um but it is it also has one
eye to the future as well in terms of
the transcendent
form of health and social care that will
happen over the longer period
and we're working with our partners to
refine
um and develop the very tangible and
practical action plan and one of the
great things that came out of our last
steering group meeting
um where joshua uh vulture joined us
from who's been working in the public
health team around all the excellent
engagement working communities
is that the reach of the existing
steering group that meets
again is is broader again so we have a
fantastic set of partners there who are
willing and able to
get those messages out into parts of our
communities that we might not
necessarily be reaching at the moment so
i'm picking up everyone's
points from the previous conversation
around making sure that it's consistent
it's reaching
our communities where we needed to to
reach
um we've taken the draft strategy um to
our local care alliance meeting just a
couple of weeks ago
um and if acceptable by colleagues on
this call and andrew and if we could
bring that back here
maybe in the next week or so for
people's
uh opinions and comments um with an idea
that we would take that's the health and
well-being board in the middle of
october
for sign off and but absolutely this is
about us working together as a system
one action plan we all know our roles
and responsibilities
and and that we have that consistent
comes and i know that is something
that's been evident throughout govid
but this is about strengthening and
widening partnership and giving us a
platform for
for the longer term as well um that's
without going into much more of the
detail
and the actual talk and the strategy
itself
um which does pick up around brand key
messaging the channels and
methods that we have as as system
partners to utilize
um without going into all the detail of
that i think this is as i said before in
summary working together
and so i'll probably pause there and
just take on um trace if there's
anything you would like to ask them
please feel free to
and um i guess the other key thing to
note
is it was mentioned around um
at our last meeting that we need a bit
more of a coordinated approach so we
really are celebrating the engagement
we're doing
and collating that information so
actually directly after this meeting
there is going to be an engagement next
like a subgroup from our group as well
trying to work with partners about what
we are doing
using our insights and i'm just thinking
actually um
andy lay them i think that that will be
really helpful for the findings from
your health and social care
and piece of work as well to actually
discuss and coordinate and then be able
to feed back to yourselves as well
so that's a real positive
any question
any questions or comments on that thanks
tom thanks tracy
i mean i think i think the the work of
that group that tracy's just mentioned
will be which is also the next agenda
item and i think laura will be able to
talk a bit more about it
but that's absolutely critical and that
should be really the group that's
driving the
um you know we will be looking to this
public engagement board
for a steer to support the work of that
group but also we will want that group
to be held to account
by this board to make sure that the
actions that are coming out of that
board
um that group um reflect the
the um the wishes of this group but also
so that we have that um accountability
but also
um some some more people on the ground
doing that work
um so it again it leads neatly into the
next item um which helen
was going to join i think helen collins
are struggling with them
logging on this morning um
better down but uh laura i don't know do
you want to could you
talk a little bit about the group and
how it's being set up
yep so um so yeah so we've established a
kind of a a coordination engagement
group we're calling it
to help i guess support the work of this
board
and to help coordinate the engagement
response across the locality
so we're obviously aware that there's
loads going on but it's just trying to
pull it into one place
and the idea is that we have on a weekly
basis we'll have the
information from um the data dashboard
that we view
and we'll be able to kind of set out
some enhanced kind of action plan
so reviewing the data understanding
where there might have been spikes in
different
areas and then working together as a
locality
to to try and set out what actions um
we've kind of completed last week
and then new actions for the following
week
and so we've got representation across
various different teams within the
council
we've got strategic growth we've got um
tracy and martin from commons engagement
we've got guys from the data lab
and we've got representation from gmp
and
so i think the first meeting is today
and
the idea is that we'll update the sort
of 10-point action plan and have this
enhanced kind of action plan weekly and
then hopefully we'll be able to get some
representation from various different
folk
on on this board to provide a bit of an
update on the work that they've been
under
undertaking and with a view to to kind
of having
some further support um from from
yourselves
if if needed
that sounds um really useful actually as
a piece of work are there any any
questions or comments on that i'm sure
um people will be happy to feed in um as
needed moving forward but
um any anything from anybody on that
note
tracy's just suggested to include
healthwatch on the that group
very good idea yeah so um yes please so
andrew um
we'll be sending you an invitation um
yep that's fine happy to be involved in
that right
so so having looked at the community
engagement coordination group we now
have enhanced community engagement
which which sounds like a very similar
uh theme to be honest
because i don't think that law or
anything else i think i think we can
merge those two yeah um probably covered
that
yeah i mean i think i think the main
thing with this is trying to make sure
that we
give consistent messages but that the
messages
speak to the different subpopulations
because messaging that will work with 16
and 17 year olds will be very different
for messaging that will work with 50
year olds and so on and so
forth so it's really trying to make sure
that we um
we hear from people what what their
issues are and we design the messaging
um appropriately um so that would so
that we
we can try and provide i think people
have got you know the messaging
it is trying to make sure that we can
give really clear
simple messages um that people can
can live by
um looking at the next three items they
they seem to be standing items on the
agenda around the
identify uh identifying leads and key
themes
um and actions and then resources and
risk locks so i'm not sure if there's
anything in particular
um that anybody was looking to draw out
of those three
this time appreciating that that they
were also on the agenda
last time but feel free to come in
if they're if there are any queries on
those
i'm going to as i've just got back from
holiday i'm going to hand over to donna
and laura for those
um if there's anything specific we're
looking for
at the moment from this group
so i think just just any i mean we've
we've obviously setting up this group so
if there's any further sort of
representatives so we'll add healthwatch
into that but if there's anything else
that that you feel
that that the work of that group could
help support this group
um or any further representation
obviously just just let us know
um the idea in terms of resources and
capacity is that helps the kind of
capacity
build and coordinate the work
i suggest in terms of um risk log i
think if we hold
i mean health protection board holds
holds a risk log
on behalf of this program and that
includes any risks
around community engagement and the
action planning around that
so my suggestion is that we have a kind
of essential risk log
for the programme and any risks that
would be helpful for this members of
this group to help us
unblock we'll escalate those as and when
okay so if we leave it as a standing
item but only
really end up taking that by exception
that seems
um sensible tom did you want to come in
yes just a very quick one i was building
on my previous point uh
laura around the sort of the enthusiasm
and commitment of that existing steering
group that's been meeting for nine
months
there's a range of different partners of
all shapes and sizes from across
trafford and beyond
uh who work above and beyond traffic who
are willing to help
in any way that they can and they were
really um
they're really committed and so just
making sure that
that opportunity gets sent out as well
just lays with you behind the scenes to
make sure we get the information out to
that wider
set of partners and so they can be
involved and help
and anything from anybody else on on
those
um or i mean we have um
a sort of capture with either items for
escalation or
um any other business i think i think a
lot of us are probably waiting to see
what comes out at 11 o'clock
um to be honest as that will guide a lot
of the
um comms engagement and response from
the next
few days potentially so um
is there anybody who wants to wants to
come in with any anything any
suggestions
or anything that's worrying done um
you know in terms of um anything going
on that they think the board should be
aware of
no okay well
on that basis then i will
um draw the meeting to a closer we set a
date for the next meeting already
forgive me i've not got it
um in front of me alex but is is that
agreed or is that to be
um confirmed
uh i believe that um we've got a
schedule in place for about the next
uh 25 million so but yeah the next one
should be agreed but if there are any
issues please let us know
okay yeah that's that's great
okay um well then that brings us brings
us to um
actually a fairly as well a fairly
slippery clothes but it means that we
can
watch the 11 o'clock if people are able
to do so so
um thank you very much for your time
everybody um and
thanks eleanor and the team for
everything that you're continuing
um to do i know it's absolutely manic so
um thank you very much for that okay
thanks everybody and i will see you all
soon
thank you